we are looking at Vector equations of
curves today so I want you to remember
back to last week we're looking at
Vector equations of lines and one of the
reasons why we were looking at Vector
equations of lines is because in
three-dimensional space if you just want
to do something as simple as write the
equation of a line it turns out a
Cartesian equation makes it quite
challenging actually we really needed
three Cartesian equations sort of all
together that we call them the
parametric equations you bought them a
lot together but why say three when you
can just say one and we need Vector
notation for that so that's why we did
the vector equation of a line now we're
going to extend that as you might expect
it's like I can I do more things than
just straight lines and the answer is
yes you absolutely can and what we're
going to do is we're going to dive into
like what's the simplest kind of curved
thing that we can consider in 3D space
it's a it's a sphere a sphere is the
simplest kind of object in three
dimensions and so in order to think
about sphere I want us to go back to two
dimensions and think about circles now I
know or I hope and I am expecting that
if I asked you uh you could all give me
a Cartesian equation like an X and A Y
equation for a circle that's not one I'm
going to ask for just yet we'll return
to that idea I actually want you to
think about circles in the complex plane
do you remember when you're doing
complex numbers we actually did uh we we
had a brief look not just at the numbers
um like oh X Plus i y is over here or
you know R plus cos Theta R times cos
theta plus I sine Theta rather is over
there right we also looked at graphing
regions or sets of complex numbers on
the complex plane and the equation of a
circle is really nice and simple in
complex number language does anyone
remember it
X Plus
X
Plus i y I'll just start by writing that
what else do we need to add around that
by the way
the radius yep yep so we would say very
good yeah both of you said it together
so um first we do want the modulus of
that complex number it's its distance
from the origin and then we would say
that's equal to the radius or you could
be even more succinct than that and you
could just say the absolute value or the
modulus of Z is the radius now what this
would give you is a circle on the
complex plane uh its radius would be R
where would its origin be by the way
yeah that's right it would be at the
origin because that's what that's what
modulus means right this literally means
what is your distance from zero zero so
being that this is a circle with Center
on the origin maybe I might mention that
uh Center
zero zero
radius r
would we adjust this so that we could
have a circle that has a different kind
of Center how would we write it in
complex numbers I'll give you a clue it
starts very simple simply like we had
before there's a modulus and then
there's a radius but we need to change
something what do we need to change
yeah okay so let's just do that as an
example right yeah if I if I said ZIP
plus one okay what you're doing is
you're no longer measuring uh the
modulus from zero zero you're measuring
the modulus from in this case it would
be the point negative one uh on the
um on the real axis right um and I could
change that right I could say hey how
about Z minus I now I would be measuring
from
um I up on the imaginary axis right and
of course I can put any complex number
that I like in there you just have to be
careful though if I gave you something
like Z minus uh two plus three I equals
R just be cautious right what is the
center of this circle where am I
measuring from
yeah two minus three I so this is one of
those spots that we often encountered in
graphing where things are sorted
backwards so just as a to give a much
simpler example if this is fizzling your
brain out because it's been a little
while since complex numbers right if you
think about an equation like uh y equals
x minus two all squared so you can
picture the parabola that goes with this
right it's a parabola that doesn't have
its vertex of the origin its vertex is
at
positive two yeah it's moved in the
other direction so that that negative
there you have to kind of read it in the
opposite direction and it's the same
thing with this right I would write this
as Z take away and then I put 2 minus 3i
in Brackets because that whole complex
number is really one piece okay by the
way I don't know if you um remember this
but that's the whole point of the word
complex I actually live uh myself like I
didn't make this I didn't choose this to
make it a good illustration but I live
in a complex of townhouses and what that
means is there's a bunch of like they're
not freestanding individual houses there
are a bunch of smaller houses and
they're all kind of jammed up one next
to another so like I share a brick wall
with my neighbor
um our houses are one kind of singular
thing even though we live separately and
that's the whole deal with complex
numbers even though there's a real part
and an imaginary part they really are a
single thing together two minus 3i is
one complex number so I don't know if
you realize that was why we called them
complex now this is what we did in the
complex plane right and what I want to
um point out to you is that complex
numbers they're vectors right there's a
direction and there's magnitude and so
this way of writing circles in the
complex plane directly translates into
how to do uh number one circles in two
Dimensions with Vector notation or we
could do spheres in three dimensions
with Vector notation so let me try and
show you how that works uh let's do
circles and this time I'm going to say
with Vector notation
so we wouldn't normally say Z when we're
talking about vectors right if we had
some Vector what's like a generic thing
to call the vector
what letter when we use
okay yes sorry you said it I think and I
didn't quite hear it um R is a very uh
ordinary letter to use like we use that
quite frequently we used it a lot when
we were doing Vector equations of lines
can anyone suggest for me why in this
particular context r ends up not being
the best choice
just R's the radius yeah very good so
it's kind of like they're both fighting
it's like hey I'm R for the equation of
Alliance and like I'm off a radius well
in this case radii win so we tend to
write
um the the vector just as well crazy
right V for Vector so what we've got is
the modulus or in this case we would now
say the magnitude of vector v
is equal to well it's the same deal we
just want a radius right so this is the
equation of uh in in two Dimensions uh a
circle with Center origin and radius r
um if I wanted to move where the center
was it's just like what you saw before
if I were to try and uh generalize what
you can see over here it was Z take away
some complex number right and that
complex number represented the center
whether it was negative one or I or two
minus three I right so if I were to
generalize I would say again this sum
Vector which we're measuring the
distance to and then you just subtract
the position Vector that corresponds to
wherever you want your Center to be and
because it's a center we just we tend to
by convention just call it C
so that again is going to be equal to
our radius okay now I just said that
this is for circles in Vector notation
but in fact this sort of Dual Purpose
actually acts also for spheres because
so I'm just going to put spheres here
along the side
if what we did was say put a vector in
here that had an X and A Y then you'd
say oh of course it's Circle we're in
two Dimensions right but there's no
reason why I can't insert into there a
vector that's a three-dimensional vector
and it's still the same notation right
we would still use V to indicate three
dimensions it's just that if you
expanded that out for example
you might something write something like
say the magnitude of uh you know one
zero negative three and now suddenly
you're in three dimensions okay so this
is still the magnitude of a vector
equals some arbitrary radius maybe I'll
just say radius two and that there is
the equation of a sphere it's not a
circle anymore because I know I'm in
three dimensions so a bit strange that
you can use this same notation for two
Dimensions or three dimensions but to me
this is a callback too uh what we saw
with the dot product right the dot
product in two Dimensions is the same as
the dot product in three dimensions